they are still pushing out ads on
vaccines and boosters uh for not only
people you know let's say middle agesh
but for young people and pretty much
everybody and they've got celebs doing
the Hawking Forum here's John Legend
okay I know I'm talking to every parent
out there life with little kids can be a
juggling act Luna's got dance miles has
basketball plus they both have school
and their own personalities
and now we've got a little baby in the
house but I wouldn't trade being a dad
for anything in the world I love being
there for my special moments with my
kids that's why my health is such a
priority to me and why I got an updated
covid-19 booster my family did too I
encourage you to talk to your health
care provider and go to vaccines.gov to
check eligibility and schedule an
appointment today
all right a couple things here I don't
know how much he got paid for that but
it was obviously a paid advertisement
even though it didn't look like an
advertisement it just looked like a
selfie video in essence um just on a
personal note uh my partner David my
husband David has covid right now as do
our two a six-month-old and a
four-month-old and we spoke to our
pediatrician and basically she said uh
just keep giving him breast milk a lot
of love a little fresh air when you can
make sure they're elevated a little bit
when sleeping if possible and then and
they're already all on the mend the idea
that I would be injecting them with
anything or would have injected them
with this stuff beforehand is completely
insane uh Heather it's just never gonna
stop right I mean I think that's sort of
what you're alluding to and what you're
seeing in New York City that these the
ads the behaviors it seems like we've
crossed some bizarre threshold here even
though Rob is saying you know some
people are putting some of it behind but
the the general movement of this thing
seems like it's just going to keep going
forever yes the New York Times still
publishes its weekly Coronavirus update
that purportedly shows hot spots in the
country there are none you know there's
these little sort of Cloudy Dots here
and there that have maybe like three
people with covet or five people in the
hospital of course we still are counting
uh hospitalizations with covid as
hospitalizations for covidson with the
death rate but yes uh there's a there's
a core constituency committed to
safetyism it runs universities uh it's
it's highly female and they are not
willing to allow people to go back to a
sense of individual risk calculation or
governments to go to a sense of of
rational policy making that balances
cost versus risk and and
celebrates uh entrepreneurship and risk
taking instead we're all supposed to
cower under the thumb of our government
overseers
if you'd like more sane takes on our
insane World check out our direct
message clips playlist and if you want
to watch more full episodes of our live
roundtables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell